Good morning, John.
Last week I sent you a song about your inflamed
nervous system using the instrumental song
from Calvin Harris's dance song "Summer."
This was a blatant violation of copyright.
I just stole it! But somehow, that's okay.
We live in a brave new copyright world and
the solutions really aren't legal anymore,
they're technological.
So for the people out there who are making
content and are confused about copyright,
this is the bizarre state of intellectual
property in the United States, in four minutes.
Okay. Intellectual property is the idea that
you can own things that are not physical objects,
but are still things. There are three different
ways to own intellectual property in the U.S.
If you just create something, like I'm creating
this video right now, that is protected by
copyright. I own this video. Cause I made
it!
Ideas though, cannot be copyrighted. They
can sometimes be patented. Though obviously
the idea of controlling an idea is a little
bit more weird and scary.
So the U.S. government regulates patents.
You have to apply for them, and be granted
them.
And finally we have trademarks, where you
want to assign a symbol or a set of words
to a corporation or a product. Like the logo
of McDonald's and the word McDonald's and
the phrase "I'm lovin' it" are all trademarked
by McDonald's, so another person can't set
up a restaurant that looks and acts and sounds
like McDonald's but isn't owned by McDonald's.
For the average person who creates or enjoys
creations, copyright is the most interesting
one of these, and it started out very simple.
The idea was hey, I made a bunch of words
in an order. And thus I should be able to
own those words in that order, and someone
else can't come along and put all those same
words in that same order and say "This is
now my book and you can buy it from me."
Which is something that actually used to happen
all the time. To make that law, you say that
you have to have the rights to make a copy
of the thing and you call it copyright.
Simple! No it's not. In order to critique
a work or to critique society, sometimes you
have to use little bits of the things that
society creates. Say I want to make a video
on violence in contemporary cinema. I might
want to use a clip from Reservoir Dogs to
help me illustrate my point. That should be
- and is - legal. It's called Fair Use. Basically
that's the use of copyrighted material for
societal good. And it also has to be inside
part of another work that could not exist
in the same way without the use of that copyrighted
material.
Now there are things that are definitely fair
use and that no one will sue you for, because
any judge in their right mind would call it
fair use. But that doesn't necessarily mean
that it IS fair use; the only person who can
decide whether something is fair use or not
is a judge. Which brings me to the bizarre
state of copyright today, especially on YouTube.
It's much more of a technological system than
it is a legal one because there is too much
content. There is no way a lawyer could
look at every single video that was uploaded
to YouTube! So YouTube has like a robotic
lawyer that looks at literally every single
video that's uploaded to YouTube and then
compares it to a library of, like, just a
massive amount of intellectual property. Every
song ever released, every movie ever made,
every television show ever put on TV - it's
called Content ID and it's actually kind of
a little bit of a miracle. Like what, really,
you can do that?
So if I upload that video of me talking about
violence in contemporary American cinema,
and the Reservoir Dogs clip is in there, the
Content ID will say, "Yes, there is a clip
of Reservoir Dogs," and then they will give
the owner of Reservoir Dogs, whoever that
is, the right to do whatever they want with
that video. They could do nothing, they could
take the video down, or the most likely thing
that they will do is they will monetize that
video for themselves. It's basically like
me paying a retroactive license for the use
of Reservoir Dogs in my video. But I shouldn't
have to do that because it's fair use. So
then I would dispute that copyright claim
saying that it's fair use and then whoa, who
knows where it goes from there? I actually
made a whole video about it on hankschannel,
you can watch it.
But this is why I can basically steal Calvin
Harris's song and not worry about it, because
now I get to pay a retroactive license to
Calvin Harris. I don't get to monetize that
video, Calvin Harris gets the money, but at
least this way I don't have to worry about,
like, trying to make a deal with Calvin Harris's
record label at freakin ten o'clock at night
on a Thursday.
But the big point here is that this is not
the best solution. It's not the most legal
solution, it's not the fairest solution. What
it is, is the most possible solution. Really
the only possible solution. And frankly, it's
kinda cool. I get to violate copyright without
having to worry that my YouTube channel is
gonna get taken down, YouTube gets to not
be sued out of existence, and rights holders
get another alternate revenue stream so they
can have bigger and more fancy yacht parties.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.